he was so stupid and I was stupid too
and then he'll hey what's that answer
homie and I'll give it to him when we
failed he'll be like hey you Fu stupid
homie he BL it on you I'm like but
you're dumb too like what the you say
homie no I'm just saying I'm dumb I'm
sorry for being dumb it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
what all right so um Jesus I'm going to
show you something thing and I just want
you to to let it Channel all of the
deepest feelings that come from this
don't hold anything back that means but
okay let it all out oh really like watch
this and yeah just watch this this going
to pop out though right no no it's not
going to pop out but just give us your
thought wait wait wait wait wait you
have to prep me for this what are we
doing the
okay cuz uh do you need to get something
first or just do it just do it hold on
yeah oh yeah perfect PR perfect PR
what's your name oh wait let me turn
this up sorry wait hold on dude off the
bats I love pervy voice nothing gets to
go fan ofast hello girl am I a fan of
Clint Eastwood yeah [__] oh dude
you're about to see C dub dude you're
about to see Clint East dub come on man
hold on dude the original
CW what's your name
girl
but everybody calls me Amy oh that's
right John MC Bernie but everybody calls
me
[Laughter]
MCB
12 13
and nothing
kisses yeah
baby yes and we got [__] shirts
baby look at this we got old up for
kisses we got is 12 but 13 in September
you get a shirt you get a shirt you get
a shirt you get a shirt you get a shirt
you can go get the shirt right now click
the
description that's what I'm talking
about baby 12 but 13 in December Baby
sep hold it up for kisses December
September who cares D it's September
right now it's December now yeah that's
why I said December I [__] love you
guys dude this is [__] awesome what
do you what do you think of that man I
love it I loved everything about it you
love everything about it yes symbolism
for a menstrual cycle my God oh my
goodness that's a symbolized for that
[__] slash it's just designed it's
supposed to be Clint Eastwood's face in
that clip the little Mark yeah why is he
has like camo on it's that little slash
oh dude when you're dude you got to be
in the woods can't you got to be CT yeah
dude you got to be in the wood if you're
you can't be out in the open yeah dude
you got to wear cam here is the thing
dude what if you rock this shirt and
someone's like yo what do that shirt
mean like Ewood I'll be like how old are
you 25 not old enough walk away dude the
perfect thing about this shirt is you
wear this and it's a party conversation
they're like what is this and then you
play that video and then you see the
reactions on their faces and then they
they they just bump you down the ladder
in their head and they're just like what
the [__] go you bought that shirt my
boss gave it to
me Joe's like no we made him we produced
them you see that old creepy guy in the
back he's like I like that
shirt who he knows before you say what
do you do when you start realizing all
the same people the same clientele are
buying these shirts hopefully they're
just JK fans also how did you find a
clip and Steve Green showed it to us one
day dude that [__] is hilarious I love
everything about that clip because Steve
saves all these types of Clips on his
hard drive it reminds me of being young
and you watch a that movie and you're
just like these guys are out of their
[__]
mind and the the fact that that's what
used to be the thing it makes me it
makes me laugh cuz it's like we don't
have that comedy no more to me it's like
some people watch these movies I don't
think that was comedy that's what I'm
saying some people watch it just like oh
yeah that's what I'm talking about and
the other some people of us smoking just
laughing at these movies like yo that's
[__] crazy we why it remember that
movie you would just be like rewind that
part and it's supposed to be serious but
you're just laughing how stupid it is
that's what I'm talking about it's weird
too because I guess I love the trivia of
that clip is that he wasn't meant to
kiss her he improved oh really yeah this
[__] C duub being C dub oh Clint uh
sorry you weren't supposed to shut up
that's why he wanted to be a director
well you're
next like for him being a what a line
what a guy great line he's got games
yeah that's Riz that's that's that's
that's remember that Viral one where the
Asian guy was uh he had glasses and he
was smoking me and he was like yo I got
to get a constipation meds I hate that
guy yeah and then like that guy you're
like dude that guy like this is czy that
guy needs to be gone as a kid eliminated
if I was a kid I I was like yo I'm out
this guy what the [__] but it is true it
would be really weird if open up for
kisses yeah I would have been like that
would be wild to be confronted to
confronted guy who's just like and so
what like oh [__] that's the guy who's
going to buy this [__] shirt now guys
thanks a lot for promoting it the right
way we'll see him at the water park no
buy this shirt cuz you know what put
your shirt on let me tell you something
this shirt represents how funny and
stupid that clip is that's what that is
dude what do you think break down the
line old enough for kid what do you
think about that line here's the thing
dude you know what I say that to my wife
a lot now o e
fkk kisses what a line what that's
America right there back in the day hold
enough for kisses you know what I'm
saying see M and dream hey man I I
[__] you know I get it back in those
times uh if it wasn't for my grandma and
grandpa you know what I mean I wouldn't
be here yeah same what that even mean as
then if she wasn't old enough for kisses
uh my grandpa you know what I mean would
have never went in for a kiss I wouldn't
be here I say that to dogs all the time
before I make out with
them dogs how old are you yeah cuz
they're usually underage cuz most dogs
don't survive past 14 12 years old yeah
that's true or 18 but they got dog years
to add up to that I'm all trying to all
dogs are 12 all dogs are minor or 13 in
September all dogs are 12 all dogs are
miners good God all dogs are young what
else do you think what do you what else
do you think this could be
misinterpreted as well it could be that
know the context I'm not 12 no more I'm
13 also if you're Latino you're walking
around with the 13 very brave
oh yeah it uh another good selling point
okay if it's not Friday the 13th
September SE 13 homie what the [__] they
can't read they might
think 13 is
it no that's their gang Joker no this is
September Joker no joker
no you only gang bang in September homie
like no dude God damn it Jer September
never dropped out of Middle School dude
the [__] is wrong with you you know I
get confused with with the letters homie
actually looks really tight
though dude I had a stupid ass chollo
bully dude I hated that guy but he was
so stupid and I was stupid too and then
he'll hey what's that answer homie and
I'll give it to him when we failed he'll
be like hey you [__] stupid
homie he playing on you I'm like but
you're dumb too like what the [__] you
say homie no I'm just saying I'm dumb
I'm sorry for being dumb it's
what I don't know how you flipped it on
me like I might feel worse he hang out
with another [__] white boy hey that
[__] stupid homie [__]
smart the [__] white Bo like yeah
he's [__] he's [__] real stupid
like roasting you homie roasting yeah
yeah so [__] dude uh I love it thanks
for the [__] gift I can't wait to
wear it and show my girl she's going to
be like what the 12 and the how are you
going to explain it to her you got to
show her the video how do you think
she'll take it and then cut to her going
like what the [__] and I'm like I know
right that's what I'm talking about we
should she like yeah dude the homies at
JK she's like I don't want you hanging
around with them you can't go there
anymore don't we should put like send
this with a QR code or maybe we should
have put a QR code link to that video so
people could check out oh that would be
genius dude you just take a picture like
have it queued up when you're whenever
you're wearing the shirt just have it
ready that's my favorite line dude my
favorite line is the [__]
old that's a crazy line what a bar but
it commun is excited about that bar the
the editor's room the director room so
everyone was cool with it back then Bart
has a point it's just it's a chain
before it goes out on theaters it's a
goes through a couple of fil even before
DVD and there's a couple of old men that
are watching this at least 30 eyes saw
it after they finished filming just
different standards back then it was 79
it left the executive room and saying
like send it wasn't there that one movie
where there's that last scene where that
guy puts that girl in that little uh
elevator thing and then she goes down
and he [__] makes out with her and
then but then she goes down at the end
and then he he [__] but then it was
like why you making out with a kid okay
what is this there's a movie talking
about the professional I was going to
say the movie that made me very
uncomfortable was the professional they
made out did they make out I don't know
if they made out but was that the one
with Nellie partman yeah the whole I
thought they made out but the whole
movie I was like are they going to are
they going to [__] like what's going on
here there's like so much sexual tension
really there's sexual tension in the
movie I thought it was sexual tension
everybody was like no it was like a bond
with a child and adult I'm like yo I
don't know what movie you're watch
that's what I thought I was like I
thought it's rescue hostage but then
he's like in love with her and I was
like if a listen if I am an
assassin right and I'm out here trying
to kill and there a little kid asking
question shut the [__] yeah yeah get the
[__] out of here I'm not kicking it with
the kid the kids get the [__] away from
I thought the point that it was like
softening him as a person oh he didn't
soften him at all dude got him hard as a
rock cuz I saw a different energy
between those two I was like yo I wonder
if other people have that same take I
bet I bet I bet a lot of people think
that though when they see the
professional what if in the commentary
it's that's what it is and my friends
are like like here's where he gets
turned on here's right here dude they're
not going to [__] and then there's
moments where they lock in eyes and
looking at each other I'm like they're
[__] like they're not going to dude
get out of here what do you think of
this cover this is the movie that we
just saw that we just saw what is that
movie about what is even about yeah yeah
yeah yeah what's the movie apparently
he's got like um a relationship with
like a bunch of different women in that
like from like different professions
whether they're like a a nurse like a
school teacher to like a kid or whatever
did he write this movie he's just a
womanizer [__] Clint is like how
about I just [__] everything inside yeah
yeah it's called the be gilded the the
writer the writer I guess he
get why would you name something so
weird I don't even know what that means
beg I don't what what does begu mean
let's look it up what we just saw a
negative thing it sounds like one of
those old words that nobody uses smart
or something right or like crafty is
that what it means gu what does that I
thought it was a white guy on Street
Fighter impress right now if you're
right H I'm really impressed if you're
right Sonic Boom to charm or enchant
someone oh so that's his in a deceptive
way he's the he's risen everybody up oh
it's it's an old version for Riz rizen
everybody even kids oh so the modern one
you know how they remake old films they
should call it the rizzler the rler they
did remake it already oh really 2017
yeah a begu yeah of the begu but they is
he kissing kids no they don't have that
party so who took who took his role
Colin frell oh yeah dude Colin farell
it's Colin Ferell Kirsten dun Nicole
Kidman El Fanning it's like a Powerhouse
so he to [__] all these girls Colin
phell if if his [__] car breaks down
and he comes in just to use the phone
he's not coming in my house all right
lock your kids lock your grandma lock
everybody up don't let him in so he's
[__] something cuz once he's in he's
he's going to get his hands on you I
feel like some of the these guys though
they just use this excuse to kiss all
these girls on scene because they're
like oh man here's a movie I'm going to
be like 50 of the hottest girls right
now I'mma put on film and I'm going to
just make a story where we just had to
kiss all day yeah some of these [__]
uh Hollywood [__] writer and
directors are living their pervy lives
through [__] it's
art they want to see some weird [__] and
it's like bro that's this is the weird
ass time to do another take and another
one another take CL take your time oh
the lens was on we got to reshoot it so
here's the story of because like we've
never we've never seen the actual film
and most people haven't but uh it's the
story is that it's in the middle of the
Civil War and he's a a dude from I think
the union side that deserted the war so
he's hiding on the opposite side that's
why he's in the bushes like that so then
like he he ends up like uh kind of
seducing these different women of this
boarding school or like a town and then
uh causes them to have their own Civil
War in away let me tell you something
dude I daydream this scenario all the
[__] time I always tell myself I went
to Iraq son and I went to Iraq and I
would literally be yeah let go let go go
go go then I'll [__] change it to
normal [__] and I'll just be out with
the people and just have a [__]
fest and I wck all right find me some
yeah find me some of them [__] you
know some them Iraqi girls you know what
I mean best in Iraq I never thought I
would hear those what what other
countries would you go do you guys want
to watch the actual trailer to this
movie it's kind of short yeah cuz I have
zero context I think having we got to
watch the whole I kind of want to watch
the movie now well here's the
trailer uh-oh oh my God oh my God is
right [__] is he going to jump down and
kiss her don't even got shoes on he got
the union pants
on oh get the [__] that many women relax
guy is brought to an all girl school to
become the prisoner of these man
deprived women
who these man deprived women this has to
be a porno bro this is some 70 [__] for
sure I'm clean oh [__] [__] is
mine I wash his
dick these men deprived women what
happened to you he's like oh
yeah [__] my
age so it's kind of like a horror film
on his end possib this like misery but
like kind of tight misery dude don't get
it this ooh even the hell gets it
they're all trying to [__] poor guy is
drained dude his balls are drained he's
[__] going through it he goes I can't
stand
it oh damn toay alive we must love to
stay alive that's probably how he
rationalized it he's like I kiss every
woman I have to kiss her too this
place I got to keep the piece by [__]
them
all the only way to survive is the [__]
this is Hil oh no not another man get
him out of there yeah you got to kill
him dude that's all your [__] guy oh
another guy oh there's a bunch this is
my chicken coop this is my chicken coop
yeah he's got to kill all those guys so
he can make love to those sweet sweet
ladies too many [__] testicles around
here this move's kind of fire bro seual
the sexual enemy oh she's trying to [__]
block he's going to kill
her he's going to kill her a
[__] are those kisses on the side of his
head
Elizabeth passion latent and violent hit
it late and violent oh she she going bad
on him too and then they're going to
[__] start
kissing you ly
FY I hope you're dead the tensions the
jealousies the conflicts of seual
confrontations rare even for
today rare even for today even for today
bro everyone wanted to [__] them and
then they got mad when they found out
everyone yeah that is do you don't
understand how many times I dreamed this
scenario you know how many times I
dreamed this not only when it comes to
war but I would always be like yo
imagine if I like my parents moov to a
small town population maybe 5,000 and I
went to a school with all hot ass girls
and only two dudes and the other guy's
ugly I'm the only hot guy in town you
don't you understand me all these hot
ass girls have to compete with me every
day Jus is like all right I guess we'll
[__] yes it's like I'm so tired all
right but make it quick they bully you
they they just corner you in the
bathroom and stuff just [__] you all
day like that ripping the shirt being
like God like a shot of this and people
just kissing me I'm like oh God es
especially if you're a wounded soldier
bro if you're a wounded student and
everyone has to take care of you that's
a dream the things I J dream about I
dream about getting shot and coming to
school and surviving the shot I would be
like oh I wish I can get
shot for real I know what you're talking
about you have no many time like I I
want to get shot but survive yes like
survive surv if I know with a cool with
a cool battle scar oh for sure walking
to school like oh [__] and then wear a
muscle shirt and like what happened I
have to air it
out and the girls are like did you get
shot I'm like yeah I got I got blasted I
won't even say shot I say cool things
like blasted yeah I got [__] blasted
and [__] yeah it's all good you see the
other guy I survived you know what I
mean the other bullet came this way I
bit it and threw it away but anyways
that's all of our dreams is to be 12 but
13 in
September yeah baby link down below
shirts are available now go get it guys
let's go if you guys wear this to my my
uh if you wear it if you say if you buy
it and you come to my show you get a
free ticket how about that dude how
about that that's sick they D you have
to DM me the picture how they the shirt
oh okay you have to DM me the picture of
the shirt if someone questions you you
just say Tom I just love Tom Brady let's
go dude I just love
Tom just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just news is the man of smart
people the people of just kidding news
careful boys they are very smart just
kidding news the number one podcast in
the
world